Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Emre Göktas. Ich bin der zuständige Arzt für Sie.
Bevor wir anfangen, lassen Sie mich bitte Ihre persönliche Daten notieren.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, fragen Sie nach oder sagen Sie mir Bescheid.
Okay?
Okay, vielen Dank, Herr Doktor.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Stefanie Renz.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Vorname Buchstabieren?
Ja, natürlich. Mein Vornamen Vornamen ist Stefanie Siegfried Theodor, Emil Friedrich, Anton Nordpolider, Emil.
Okay.
Herr Renz, wie alt sind Sie?
Frau Renz. Stefanie ist ein weiblicher Name.
Okay, Entschuldigung.
Frau Renz, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 38 Jahre alt.
Verraten Sie bitte Ihr Geburtstatum?
Ja, natürlich. Das ist der 23. August 1984.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin circa 1,68 m.
Okay.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ein Gewichtswissen. So circa 62 kg.
60 kg. Okay, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet und habe eine kleine Tochter.
Und was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin Buchhalterin.
Ich arbeite in eine Bücherei.
Okay.
So, Frau Renz, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Herr Doktor, ich komme extra zu Ihnen, weil Sie mir empfohlen worden sind, dass Sie ein guter Arzt sind.
Ich habe seit vier Wochen Schmerzen an der rechten Flanke.
Ich war manchmal ganz heftig.
Und mein Hausarzt hat da nichts finden können.
Ich habe immer noch Schmerzen.
Ich mache mir so langsam Sorgen, was es ist.
Okay.
Strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwohin aus?
In letzter Zeit strahlen die Schmerzen.
Das war immer lokal begrenzt.
Aber in den letzten zwei Wochen sind die Schmerzen in den Rückenden ausgestrahlt.
Okay.
Könnten Sie bitte diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind Sie eher dumpf oder stechend oder krampatisch?
Also manchmal sind sie stechend.
Aber überwiegend eher über den Rücken hin verteilt.
Aber es ist sehr unterschiedlich. Es kommt manchmal sehr stark.
Plötzlich hält eine Zeit lang an einige Stunden und geht dann wieder weg.
Schmerzmedikamente haben am Anfang geholfen, aber in den letzten Zeit auch gar nicht mehr.
Und es ist einfach sehr belastend.
Manchmal kann es kaum laufen.
Aber dagegen, welche Medikamente haben Sie eingenommen?
Ich habe über Profil genommen, ich habe Nevalginen eingenommen.
Ich habe beides auch zusammen.
Die Zeitweise habe ich Parazitamol genommen.
Hat diese Medikamente Ihnen geholfen? Hallo?
Okay.
Hat diese Medikamente Ihnen geholfen?
Nur zu Beginn.
Danach nicht mehr.
Ich spüre keine Verbesserung.
Die Schmerzen sind immer noch da.
Deswegen nehme ich auch keine Tabletten mehr.
Gibt es etwas, was die Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt?
Zuerst hatte ich auf die Wärme ganz gut getan, aber jetzt auch nicht mehr.
Wenn ich mich bewege, wenn ich aufstehe oder laufe, dann werden die Schmerzen schlimmer.
Jetzt tut es immer weh.
Egal ob ich sitze, ob ich liege oder laufe, die sind immer da.
Vorher haben Sie eine Medikamente,
die sind immer da.
Vorher haben Sie diese Schmerzen,
die sind welchenförmiger,
kommt und wieder weg, aber seit wann ist diese Schmerzen dauerhaft?
Seit einer Woche.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Ich habe nicht.
Mein Haushalt kontrollierte auch den Urin.
Er meinte, der Urin war in Ordnung.
Dann hat er Ultraschalen gemacht.
Und auch der Ultraschalen vom Bauch und von den Nähren war auch in Ordnung.
Er hat meinen Haushalt gesagt, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das wirklich stimmt.
Aber Sie haben keine Probleme beim Wasserlassen.
Ich meine,
oder ich meine Schmerzen nicht.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Ja, ich habe ab und zu mal Verstopfungen.
Aber das ist jetzt nichts Neues.
Aber ansonsten war jetzt nichts Besonderes.
Okay.
Haben Sie diese Schmerzen,
haben Sie diese Beschwerden schon mal gehabt?
Nein, das ist das erste Mal jetzt.
Okay.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, ich bin immer so wie bisher jetzt.
Also ich habe immer zwischen 60 und 65 kg gewogen.
Aber so jetzt in der letzten Zeit abgenommen habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Okay.
Wissen Sie, sind diese Schmerzen ernähren abhängig?
Ich meine, wenn Sie ungewöhnliches Essen oder...
Ist mir bisher nicht aufgefallen,
dass es beim Essen oder bei bestimmten Nahrungsmitteln schlimmer wird.
Nein, kann ich nicht sagen.
Okay.
Müsten Sie in der letzten Zeit sehr oft aufstoßen?
Oder haben Sie Blähungen?
Ja, das habe ich gehabt,
als ich die Schmerzmedikamente genommen habe.
Da habe ich etwas Blähungen gehabt.
Aber ansonsten nicht nein.
Okay.
Müsten Sie Ihren aktuellen Anamnesern etwas hinzufügen?
Haben Sie noch irgendwelche Beschwerden?
Nein, aber das macht mir jetzt Sorgen natürlich.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es etwas Schlimmes ist
oder was man da noch machen kann.
Ich habe immer noch Schmerzen.
Und deswegen bin ich jetzt bei Ihnen.
Verhalten, können Sie diese Schmerzen
bis Ende der Anamnese verhalten?
Oder soll ich Ihnen einen Schmerzenteil geben?
Aushalten, nein.
Nein, im Moment geht das.
Okay.
Wie stark sind diese Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 0 bis 10?
Von ist keine Schmerzen, 10 ist starke Schmerzen.
Okay.
Als im Moment würde ich sagen so 3 oder 4.
Aber ich hatte die letzten Tage auch mal Phasen,
wo ich, wo das viel mehr war.
Da hätte ich gesagt so 7 oder 8.
Okay.
Leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen,
wie ein Bluthochdruck, Diabetes Militus?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Aber ich habe, ich nehme Schildrüsen-Tabletten.
Seit 5 Jahren ungefähr.
Mein Arzt meinte, ich habe seinen Knoten in der Schildrüse.
Und...
Wissen Sie, welche Tabletten nehmen Sie ein?
Das ist Ältiruxchen 75.
Okay.
Und haben Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Ich hatte mal einen Keiseschild, also meiner Tochter.
Und der Blinddarm ist wohl als Kind operiert worden.
Blinddarm und?
Und Kaiserschnitt.
Okay.
Wie war die OP für Blinddarm?
War das komplikationlos?
Ja, ja, war alles unauswährend.
Okay.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie schwere oder chronische Erkrankungen?
Also ich weiß, dass meine Mutter Diabetes hatte.
Und das ist meine Tante.
Sie hatte Brustkrebs.
Und mein Vater leidet an hohem Blut.
Okay.
Ihr habt vergessen zu fragen, seit wann haben Sie Schildrüsen-Unterfunktion?
Seit 5 Jahren.
Gehen Sie regelmäßig zum Frauenarzt?
Ja, da war ich letztes Jahr.
Sie meinte auch, das ist alles in Ordnung.
Ist Ihr Monatsblutung regelmäßig?
Ja, da habe ich bisher keine Probleme.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Eigentlich ja, aber jetzt mit den Schmerzen ist es schlechter geworden.
Ich werde immer wieder wach und kann auch schlecht einschlafen.
Aber davor war das kein Problem.
Und wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Das ist gut.
Ich kann also relativ gut essen.
Da habe ich bisher keine Sorgen.
Gibt es etwas, was Sie mich belastet?
Ja, mein Kind hat eine kleine Behinderung.
Ich muss da immer ständig zum Vertreuten.
Was für eine Behinderung hat er?
Das eine Bein hat eine komische Wirbelsäule.
Da müssen wir regelmäßig zum Kinderautopäten ein Korsett tragen.
Da wird es unsicher, ob Sie das nehmen wollen.
Sie hat Schwierigkeiten beim Laufen.
Das macht uns ein bisschen braun.
Wie alt ist er?
Er ist eine Tochter, sie ist 6 Jahre alt.
Das ist eine schwierige Situation.
Äußer Erdrohxin, nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein.
Aus der Schildgebundhabit, nehme ich nichts ein.
Rauchen Sie?
Ich habe vor 2 Jahren aufgehört.
Wie viele Jahre und wie viele Skarretten haben Sie geraucht?
Ich glaube so circa 10 Jahre.
Ich kann sagen, so im Schnitt halbe Schachtel am Tag.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Eigentlich nicht, nur ab und zu.
Wie meinten Sie auch, wie häufig trinken Sie Alkohol?
Wenn ein Feier ist oder ein Geburtstag oder ein besonderer Anlass.
Das ist einmal im Monat.
Ist bei Ihnen Allergie bekannt?
Ja, ich habe eine Venezielinallergie.
Wie äußert sich diese Allergie?
Ich bekomme immer einen Ausschlag.
Mein Hals schwillt zu.
Ich bekomme schlecht Luft.
Frau Renth, meine Seite habe ich die wichtigsten Fragen gestellt.
Haben Sie Fragen oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Mein Haushalt hat gesagt, ich habe gar einen Blasensteine.
Wer hat diese Diagnose festgestellt?
Ich meine das in meinem Ultraschall.
Das war vor vielen Jahren, ich glaube so vor circa 6 Jahren.
circa 6 Jahre.
Und ich habe auch die Frage,
ob ich das nicht mehr aufheben kann.
Wie wurden Sie behandelt?
Wegen dem Geilblasensteine.
Ja genau.
Da hatte ich bisher nie Probleme gehabt.
Das war nur ein zufälliger Befund,
als ich beim Haushalt einen Routine Ultraschall hatte.
Ich habe bisher noch keine Probleme gehabt.
Okay.
Wegen Ihre Beschwerden
sollten Sie heute bei uns bleiben,
damit wir die weiteren Untersuchungen durchführen können.
Das in Ordnung?
Ja, Doktor, muss das wirklich sein?
Ich habe wegen, wie Sie schon wissen,
die Kinder, die ich versorgen muss,
ich würde am liebsten schon nach Hause gehen wollen.
Ich wäre Ihnen sehr dankbar,
wenn Sie die Untersuchungen machen können
und mir helfen können.
Aber es wäre mir lieb, wenn ich nicht im Krankenhaus bleiben müsste.
Ja.
Wenn wir die erste Untersuchung fertig beenden,
dann können Sie vielleicht nach Hause gehen.
Aber zuerst müssen wir die ersten Ergebnisse bekommen.
Vielen Dank, Doktor.
Wie lange kann das dauern?
Nach 2 oder 3 Stunden.
Oh, so lange?
Ich würde Sie bitten, ob Sie sich beeilen können.
Meine Tochter ist allein zu Hause.
Okay, machen wir.
Welchen sehr dankbar.
Bitte warten Sie jetzt im Mathe.
Vielen Dank.
Sehr gut.
Vielleicht noch Informationen, bevor Sie die Übergabe an den Oberarzt machen.
Sie haben jetzt die Patienten untersucht.
Herz, Lunge ist in Ordnung.
Der Bauch, haben Sie auch abgedrückt, ist auch in Ordnung.
Sie haben die Klopf an den Nieren, keinen Klopfschmerz.
Aber was auffällig ist, wenn Sie die Patienten anfangen,
am Rücken zu untersuchen, sie drücken am Nacken im Schulterbereich,
entlang der Wirbelsäule, die Muskulatur, das tut alles weh.
Sie drücken auf den Muskeln, dann hat sie Druckschmerzen.
Von der Wurstwirbelsäule bis runter,
zu Ländenwirbelsäulen,
bis zu den Schmerzen, bis zu den Schmerzen.
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Ich habe mich auch sehr gut überlegt.
Wenn Sie auf die Ischias nerven,
eine Hüfte drauf drücken, das tut auch weh.
Aber Sie hat keine Ausgralung der Schmerzen in den Beinen.
Nur im Lenden-Würbeseutel.
Du Lendenwirbelsäule.
Beziehungsweise der gesamte Rückgröße,
Brustwirbelsäule,
wenn Sie drauf drücken,
an die Parabellasen,
dann ist das eine gute Frage.
Wenn Sie drauf drücken,
an die Parabellasen,
dann schmerzt alles.
Das zu Körper, die wir nun versuchen.
Jetzt machen Sie bitte den Übergabe an den Oberarzt.
Bitte schön.
Noch eine Minute bitte.
Eine kurze Verschnaufpause,
dann trinken wir noch ein Kaffee.
Haben vielleicht die Kolleginnen noch eine Frage.
Sie sind frohbereitet.
Keine Fragen.
Eine Frage hat es vielleicht noch gefehlt.
Eine Frage, aber diese braucht oder nicht,
ich weiß nicht, hatten Sie einen Unfall?
Sehr gut.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Hat es einen Unfall, ein Trauma?
Was mir noch einfällt,
das wäre vielleicht auch eine wichtige Frage.
Haben Sie erbrochen?
Nein,
keiner brechen keinen Durchfall.
Trauma-Geschichte?
Haben Sie einen Unfall?
Kein Kribbelgefühl.
Am Rücken,
hatte ich manchmal Stechen und Kribbeln.
Manchmal ist es so,
dass mir die Fingerspitzen etwas kribbeln und taub werden.
Ich habe ein bisschen mit dem Doktor begonnen.
Er hat gesagt,
dass es bei uns ein Brieffarm ist.
Wir sehen uns dann auch.
Natürlich.
Es ist sehr schwierig.
Auf Deutsch bitte die Frage.
Haben Sie einen Brief?
Die Befunde von Ihrem Hausarzt.
Die Laborbefunde.
Den Ultraschallbefund.
Sehr gut.
Ich höre, bitte schön.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen Patient vorstellen.
Haben Sie Zeit?
Eine Patientin vorstellen.
Patientin.
Patientin vorstellen.
Frau Stefanie Rendt.
38-jährige Patientin.
Die ist 62 kg.
168 cm.
168 cm groß.
Sie ist Buchhalterin.
Sie hat eine Tochter.
Sie berichtet.
Seit 4 Wochen.
Am rechten Flanke.
Ganz heftige Schmerzen zu haben.
Diese Schmerzen.
Ausstrahlen in die.
Ausstrahlen in die Rücken.
Diese Schmerzen.
Sie sind stechend.
Plötzlich.
Vor einem Wochen.
Seit einer Woche sind diese Schmerzen dauerhaft, aber vorher sind sie wellenförmig.
Diese Schmerzen treten plötzlich auf.
Sie hat vorhin dagegen Ibuprofen, Novalgin und Paracetomol eingenommen, aber diese haben ihr nicht geholfen.
Sie hat keine Probleme beim Wasserlassen, beim Stuhlgang.
Sie hat die letzte Kontrolle beim Hausarzt alles in Ordnung.
Er hat Ultraschall und Urintest gemacht.
Diese Schmerzintensität liegt aktuell bei 3 und 4 von 10.
Aber in den letzten Tagen waren sie manchmal bei 7 und 8 von 10.
Sie hat auch am Finger Parästhesie.
Ich würde das so beschreiben. Sie hat an den Fingerspitzen Kribbelparästhesie.
Wenn Sie Parästhesie sagen, dann weiß man nicht, welche Finger sind das.
Sie leidet an einer seit 5 Jahren Hypo-Theriose.
Sie hat bei ihr Blindam entfernt.
Sie hat Appendectomy.
Sie ist bei ihr bekannt, seit 4 Jahren.
Sie hat Verstopfung.
Sie hat Stress wegen der Behinderung ihrer Tochter.
Sie nimmt regelmäßig Altroxin von 70 mg Tabletten ein.
Sie hat bis vor 10 Jahren halbischachtel täglich geraucht.
Sie hat Allergie gegen Penicillin.
Sie hat Stridor.
Was ist Ihr Verdachtstiagnose?
Ich habe die Patienten körperlich untersucht.
Sie hat Druckschmerzen zwischen Brustwerter und Landländer.
Sie hat Paravertebrale und Muskulatur.
Sie hat eine Lumbalgie verstärkt.
Nach der bisherigen Angabe gehe ich von Fibromyalgie aus.
Ich habe eine Verdachtstiagnose, die ich in Betracht habe.
Sie hat eine Fibromyalgie.
Sie hat einen Galblasenstein.
Sie hat Schmerzen.
Sie hat eine Urolithiasis.
Sie hat eine BWS-Syndrom.
Sie hat eine Url-Fentrychillin.
Sie hat eine Infekt- oder Geschmür.
Sie hat keine Gürtelförmige Ausstrahlung.
Sie hat eine Muskulatur.
Sie hat Schmerzen im Schulterbereich.
Sie hat eine Physiotherapie.
Sie hat eine Blutentersuchung.
Sie hat eine Röntgenaufnahme.
Sie hat eine gute Aussage.
Sie hat eine Nephrolithiasis.
Sie hat eine Muskelproblematik.
Sie hat eine Schmerzmedikamente bekommen.
Sie hat eine Empfehlung für eine Physiotherapie.
Sie hat eine Grammatik.
Vielen Dank.